- All right, y'all, we're
back with Garth Brooks,
and "Gratitude with Garth" in celebration
of Thanksgiving week.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- So community, it's a word
that kind of encompasses a lot.
It could be like the community
you surround yourself with.
It could be where you live.
- Sure.
- Like what are you grateful
for about?
- Well, you know,
your community on tour is the band
and crew, right?
- Yeah.
- That's your second family.
- Yeah, so now the crazy thing,
we're opening a Friends in Low Places Bar
down on Lower Broadway, right?
- I know, very excited.
- Now all of a sudden, you think about,
'cause I've always played in honky-tonks.
We have our whole lives,
but the truth is the
community in a honky-tonk,
in a bar,
- Yeah.
- forgive me for using the word church,
but this is where you
come to not be alone.
This is where you come
to share your problems,
raise a beer together, celebrate,
mourn, maybe sometimes.
- Yeah, or get rowdy. What?
- Amen.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
So wait, you have a big show this weekend?
- Yes.
- Yes, it's the day
after Thanksgiving.
- Yes, Black Friday.
So for the first time,
I read the NFL's doing a
Black Friday football game.
- Yeah.
- I don't know
how long it took us to think of that.
- I know, but I just got into
football, so I'm so excited.
- There you go, and so Amazon
always does the concerts
after the Thursday night football games.
- Bless you, and they're doing the game
after the Friday night one.
- Yeah.
- And they said, "Hey man,
would you do that concert?"
I said, "I would love to do it."
We're opening the bar
at the exact same time.
So we're gonna go into Friends
in Low Places Bar the first time ever
and we're gonna do a dive
bar concert in there.
We'll play some new music,
and then of course,
- Oh, my God.
- the old stuff.
- I'm so mad I'm not gonna be
here. (audience applauding)
That's gonna be incredible.
- How do you get in?
You're gonna love this.
We just launched the The BIG 615,
the global country music
station, it's awesome.
So what I love about it is
the only way you get in,
you just listen and you register.
So the people that you're
gonna play for that night,
they don't have to have a lot of money,
they don't have to have a certain look
about 'em or where they work.
It's just luck of the draw.
- I love that.
- So it's gonna be fantastic.
It's fun-
- You get the real fans.
- Yeah, amen.
- The ones that really
wanna be there, yeah.
- Amen, the friends
in low places, that's it.
- Yeah, I like it.
We're all about connection in this show.
It's like it's kind of my thing in life.
I just love connecting with people
and talking and communicating.
But what connections are you
like so grateful for in life?
Obviously, Miss Yearwood.
- Yeah, I can tell you this, I
learned this a long time ago.
The greatest gifts that
you will leave this planet
with are relationships, not money.
It's not anything like that.
It's just relationships.
And you never know when
you're gonna call on them.
And people say, you know,
"I can carry the world on my shoulders."
I'm telling you right now,
you cannot carry the
world on your shoulders
until someone has carried you.
You just can't, man.
- Aww.
- It's that whole empathy of
understanding how people are,
and that's what it's all about, man.
- Empathy in general.
- I'm in for that.
Empathy is a, we got a rule on the farm
that you can't say a word you can't spell.
So I can't say that word again,
but we get it once.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
But that is the word, yes.
- That's incredible.
I love that rule.
So radio, it wasn't really
important for me as a kid
'cause one, I couldn't
afford to buy a lot of music
when I was younger.
Was radio really important
for you growing up?
- Yeah.
Very, very important for me.
It's one of those things,
you know, we had gas,
well, again, before you were born,
we had gas wars and they
would give away stuff
to try and get you to come
over their gas stations
and stuff.
- Yeah.
- And we got this transistor
radio and somehow,
I confiscated, it became mine.
So you'd lay there in bed at night.
We got the Opry on WKY-AM at that point,
- Yeah.
- and then there was
a radio station called the
KATT that was coming out
that did all the rock classics.
- Oh, yeah.
- And so you'd lay there
in bed at night while everybody's asleep
with that little thing in your ear.
And that's what you'd go to bed with,
is just listening to music.
- Yeah. Oh, me too.
Well, speaking of like, finding music,
I love that we talked about it a little.
We touched on it, you
have like three channels.
- Yes.
- So the Tailgate one is
like more of a tailgate party.
That's your vibe?
- It just-
- And 615 is-
- Country music,
the entire family,
- Yeah, I love that.
- which I love, yes.
- 615 with Nashville.
That's still my number.
- It makes sense.
- Yeah, and then the other
one's The Garth Channel.
What's the difference between that one?
- Garth Channel is just as screwed up
as you could possibly be.
- (laughs) That's my favorite.
Yeah.
- It doesn't matter
because here's my theory.
- You play like James Taylor.
You play everything, yeah.
- 100%.
Great artists can follow great artists.
Great songs can follow great songs.
Merle Haggard and Beyonce
can play back to back.
- I agree, I agree.
(audience applauds)
- Great, so we do-
- You're gonna love mine.
Yeah, that's the same thing.
(Garth laughs)
I love it. First of all,
y'all just singing over there.
We didn't get to play the whole
thing, but like you, I mean,
speaking of harmonies
and just beautiful music
and everything, how do
you do that work harmony,
balance all that in your life?
How do you do that?
- Oh, I think what you do is you just run.
I mean, somebody's got a plan.
Don't try and have your own plan.
Somebody's got a plan, and
just look for your open doors.
Karma, our friendship together.
I can't tell you how hard it was
and how long it took me to text you to go,
"Hey, I got this new song
and I would love for you to,"
it's so hard for me to ask, okay?
- But I want-
- Do you wanna how long it was
for me to respond?
(audience laughing)
We can check it on my
phone. I can look at it.
And it was literally, I was like, "Oh,"
and I was like, "Yes!"
I was like...
(audience laughing)
- All capital letters.
- All capitals
with exclamation points.
- I gotta tell you, man.
- Honestly, what the hell?
- It doesn't matter how long
you've been in this business,
when someone you love
treats you back like that,
thank you.
- Oh, my God.
- That was freaking awesome.
- I will be there anytime
for you or Miss Yearwood.
- That was good.
- Y'all are my favorites, man.
- It's good.
- And the song, I said this earlier.
This song, okay, it's called
"The Ship and the Bottle".
- Yes.
- It's so beautiful.
I said yes before I even heard
the song, I'm pretty sure.
And this song, like when
I went in the studio,
and first of all,
you producing me always makes me
one (beep) Christmas turkey.
(audience laughing)
It's like I get so nervous.
It's happened twice to me,
but I was so nervous and I
was just trying to be cool.
And anyway, but how you had me sing,
nobody lets me really just sing, you know,
and not always reach for the raptures,
not always like do all the,
and it made me feel as
cool as Linda Ronstadt,
which is one of my favorite
singers and artist ever.
And like that's what the
vibe is kind of very,
it feels like it could've been released
in like the 70s.
- Yeah.
- Like, yeah, it's so cool.
- It feels good. It's just
a kind of a beachy thing.
And what I love the saying
about it is just this guy feels
like he's holding a woman back, you know?
- Mm.
- And then I start thinking
about my own relationship
with Miss Yearwood and I go,
"No wonder this sounds so
natural to sing, right?"
'Cause it's just, it's so good.
She's the ship that should be out
on the water and he's the bottle.
He just likes to drink. (laughs)
- But also the imagery of that,
like keeping in the-
- It's fabulous.
- Oh, it's so-
- So smart.
- We have to do it, you were texting me,
you were like, "Should we sing it live?"
And I was like, "We
should do a little bit."
We should do a little bit of it.
It's so beautiful.
- I will play this.
- Okay, let's do it.
(audience applauding)
- Every album comes out, we
play for the songwriters.
- Yeah.
- And there was a songwriter,
a young lady that was
in the chair listening.
She's in the captain's chair hearing it.
And I can tell she's
starting to get emotional
when the song's playing, and I'm going,
"You still got it, right?"
Because she turns around and grabs my arm
with these beautiful eyes and goes,
"My God, that's Kelly Clarkson, isn't it?"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Which is never gonna happen.
- It's so fabulous.
No, ma'am, when your voice
comes out on this record,
everybody goes and everybody
knows who it is too.
- Whatever, but I love this song
and thank you for asking me.